what's striking about looking at your
body of work is that you have lots of
lots of roles for women big and
important roles for women you know from
aiming your current and film the
assassin Lee the assassin is a woman
you've used this particular actress I
think three times shuchi who is a very
beautiful actress um is there some you
particularly like telling women's
stories or is it just is that just how
it worked out I think was just happened
naturally organically cinches a pitcher
too young no photos obenshain the Nancy
soo ji Ahn ing parent oh man GI ye
shiwen just curling content on the page
in fujian kwanghee oak you're doing
fujian the cherry seven a new guitar and
challenge the sway couldn't save
ammunition are too young oh can you chew
it happened naturally but I think one
response I would have is that for me
women are interesting because there are
more complex more diverse for me that
they're more interesting and more
layered whereas man at least from my
generation they tend to be tougher
harder so I did make movies about man I
mean I did focus on man during my career
but the things that I think in some way
they're just there they're tougher and
harder and I think I'm trying to
speculate as to why that's the case and
I think you may have to do with the fact
that you know this very patriarchal
society that we grew up in so in terms
of the symbol of power in terms of one's
relationship with one's father it's very
very nail driven so that might be
responsible for the toughness so for me
women are interesting because they're
complex they're diverging way that men
are not yeah and they're often a source
of strength in the films yeah the women
are a source of strength
mature audiences to each other that's
right because I think women are the most
powerful they are most powerful yes
phone 999 Shingen and arranges yo soy un
sonic on vampire the you in Nanda en un
Canadien pattaya nanda yemen also me on
oodle mi Minka see what's up a host of
the news in da vinci italy and visa 19yo
visa is a muffin things are harder
tougher there was some way kind of
harder to work withing away because i
think women they're more interesting
more layer and they're also more
sensitive as performances i feel like in
some way they are better performers
better actors than the men that i might
have worked with are they easier or
harder to light mark light to light yeah
doyoung you may unit the man you saw so
about the same cuz we use very few
lights yo sugah Dean tree do mostly on
bio ah yeah cuz I'm like take any for
movies we make the brightest light the
biggest life would be like 200 watts
that would be the brightest bulb we have
and maintain member mmm cafes guang Cafe
Lumiere treehouses Guang three times in
Jeju flight of the red balloon well may
your tarded don't talk on Jordan we had
really big light it was for working it
was sweet doyoung you a meal done so for
us it's all the same shooting men or
women because we don't have lights we
have very little light so it's all the
same to me wait a jiggle hononegah
Juliet Bureau she engines on uh because
of the studio pinoche was actually quite
nervous name Boyd are gentle i KN
contigo de Mayo she had one point about
her boyfriend to visit the stat just to
check out and see kind of what is
exactly
going on over here olay tell you
function but afterward they relaxed and
they were able to just trust us